the language is certainly the city in the world
with the most tiles, some even say that
lisbon has a unique light due to the amount
of tiles on the facades and
that reflect sunlight the traditional
portuguese tile and here that it is made
according to the origin according to medical tradition
I'm sorry story and spies genesis 1
g1 and
hello welcome to the santana factory my
name is francisco but i'm in charge of
the santana factory a little bit of everything
santana factory was founded in 1741 it is
currently the oldest tile factory in
the country in operation  and one
of the oldest factories in europe the
initial lisbon tile occupies a historical role
[Music]
and after our creation we have an
earthquake in lisbon so asking the
big city to rebuild the city
in search of the tile has grown
dramatically that I still don't produce
much  cheaper than stone or several
factories not height in lisbon which is
santana was one of them and plays a
key role in the reconstruction of  the city when
making and numbers closed in the
santana factory goes to everything handmade the
doctors are the meters per 18th century the
preparation of the clay first
then the molding of the clay into a
format the tile is drying for
about an e-  mail month and a half to two the
first cooking called secretly
that takes place at 100 degrees after the
tile is inscribed a product through
a sound test to confirm that
we have a stock in perfect condition
to be painted it's a rice I'll then
enter the most  magic what an
adventure
and the colors that are simple totally
different from those that we will have a
final product after the second culture and the
colors changed with a gray it can
turn into a blue or green from the oven it is always
that final breath in the process
we have cases here three  generations in a
row working at the factory I too am now
part of the third generation we
have been through remote we have been through
world wars we have been through me through
fires but we still get into it
because our
original characteristics continuity the know-how
passes from generation to generation
that keeps this art alive with
this unfolding we see each other every
day it is exhausting hard work
tiring but it is very very rewarding
there